hey how's it going it's baby bye i got a
new tv
should i say what i actually just said
i'll repeat it guys
new floor gang cup designed by
none other than the best woman in the
world mercia
i don't know if you can really see
what's happening
but it's hella cute we also got the new
branded tub
buy them both check it out i love g fuel
it tastes good and make me feel ah
and enter code pewdiepie check out and
you get a percentage off i don't
remember
if it was 20 but i think it is 20 i
don't know if i'm legally allowed to say
it's 20
just try it out all right i don't know
it's a percentage let's go
the video leave your memes on the reddit
19 year old
and i'll measure your peeps in the last
episode
do you like watching videos yes yes yes
yes but you delete them got him
santa gotti
[Applause]
[Music]
2013 i will not say his name smosh jenna
marbles pewdiepie
wait what did he quit no way he quit
he'd not quit no ten months ago no
i think he streams though bruh this
makes me think actually not
how lucky we were i wasn't there 2013
let's get real here
uh these guys are like one generation
before me [ __ ] smosh and jenna marbles
and i met have i met them all i think i
had
and they're like what some of the nicest
people i ever met that are youtubers
like we were so lucky back then
now everyone seemed like such an [ __ ]
we should have appreciated what we had
man back then it was just about
people that are awkward and wanting to
post videos online
i was like i'm gonna be the best every
day uh felix after meeting marty online
i go to italy
yep pretty much hell yeah why did this
make me laugh
i can't even tell it's boring meme like
what
i don't know 10 years ago i messaged
pewdiepie when he had
40 000 subscribers i told him he would
be famous one day he didn't believe me
daily dose of internet it's weird i
has he posted this before i have a like
a super faint memory of this
haha i'm not the next hayes i that was
the biggest guy in sweden at the time
i can't add people to skype it'll be a
mess xd
you can message me through steam group
over here anytime you want oh now i feel
like a dick for not
opening up daily dose d and me
daily dose of internet for those who
don't he's a he's a big channel
i think they had 10 mil subs or
something so he messaged me
with words of encouragement and this
[ __ ] has 11 miller himself
god damn good on you man it's cool to
see this because i remember i got a lot
of message from people saying like oh
you'll be a really big one there it's
awesome
i never believed them but it still
really made me
feel like yeah come on let's go that was
cool
that's really awesome 2011. yeah 10
years ago holy [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] bling my mind how long that
is me when my parents tell me i'm a
failure
me remembering a 31 year old swedish man
has seen my memes
three times make that four [ __ ]
the cheesecake of doom alright if i ever
see the fifth one
you get nothing sees felix in public
remember he doesn't like fan interaction
remember he has a secret code forgot the
code decided to post
i mean to get his attention and get
30k upvotes he doesn't see it otherwise
i don't mind found interaction if you
guys just want to say hi like come on i
item that's way different i'd be too
scared to say hi i'm that awkward yes
cool we'll be on the same level then it
will be great
he doesn't know i exist yes i do what
are you talking about
i even watch your dr k video that's
great first
gay couple allowed in theme parks 1932.
that's so nice thanks
just a temporary house
yes it looks so sick i'm so happy with
it dude it's gonna keep expanding and
keep expanding take over the world
pollute the earth and kill it slowly the
industrial revolution is coming into
minecraft
y'all better prepared for a longer
lifespan
of misery i have i brought some weird
energy in today's video i apologize
man yeah we i it's so weird because like
okay so here's what i said man i wish
you speed of recovery but
my brother but that ain't happening i
was referring to the fact that he wanted
the coco video back
but then i listened to it when it goes
up and i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
saying you idiot
basically what i'm trying to the point
i'm trying to get across is that you
guys aren't so epic
it's just that it's hard to understand
what you're saying what you're saying
stuff but i see it too okay
pewdiepie is a [ __ ] idiot i know
yeah i don't need you to tell me i see
it every time how it started
how's it going hell yeah 2015
i'm not your daddy i'm pretty sure i'm
not your mommy either
20 21. i'm your mommy now you win a baby
how time time changes everything doesn't
it what is this hey kids so i heard i
had to post myself next to my art hope
you like hey
that's sick well i hope you enjoy all
the sims in the comments and
have fun guys
let's let pewds know not to bring bonky
to the dragon
oh [ __ ] i'm bringing bonky to the dragon
bunky babies at last contains not safe
for work honey
you guys are such [ __ ] babies who
takes the time to report this [ __ ]
edgar no did he pee he [ __ ] peace
ah that guy you did not do that
god damn it edgar you piece of [ __ ]
you know how they say like don't wear
your sleep or whatever
don't where you eat well edgar is
everywhere you don't give a [ __ ]
who is lying mr beast or pewdiepie
bro what do you mean it was youtube
youtube deleted it
how about that big surprise me don't
tell your mama don't be a freaking
snitch
i'm being like six nine that rainbow
no response can you [ __ ] believe it
once i quit youtubing she still has a
better camera than felix
yeah well her lens broke because she
dropped it so who has the better camera
now huh
garden got him
i'm feeling very childish today i don't
know what's happening
too far stop it right there all right
you can't say that
bullying child okay so i saw this
and i changed it and it still didn't uh
fix anything
everyone always say dedicate it you
gotta dedicate the wham in your mind
quest which make it one bit bigger
it did nothing you did nothing
absolutely
why is your game green my dude oh [ __ ]
off dude
stop it look alarm
lanka lord can't believe jack drinks
from that giant bottle
jack you gotta i'll hook you up with
that same color flora gang g fuel cup
you can drink coffee from this
that'll be great my friend went to the
army left me
all his stuff i miss you
that's that's so wholesome god damn
welcome to my to find downstairs thank
you for surprising me in person great
meeting you shame we couldn't shake
hands though yeah i don't do handshakes
i told them on the spot it's coveted
time can't do that anymore
i can't tower is real oh
it fills my heart with such joy and
passion
my god it's so beautiful yay our lame
country made it
to pewdiepie submissions it's egypt
first i copied my pyramids now they're
copying my ikea tower what what the hell
egypt what you got
what's up you mean to tell me you didn't
pick the red and black
[Laughter]
yeah cause i just thought it was lame
that everything i have is red and black
so yes i didn't
oh that's [ __ ] good
i thought it was me on the left i legit
thought it was me i'm like what
am i doing there marx is weirdly uncanny
dude
jack is just uh on hard drugs i don't
know
no no no no no no felix before you go no
no no
go to the end make a backup copy of ryo
just for a small chance that the world
may be glitched
and an end platform won't spawn none of
us would want to see us end up in such
an unfortunate unfair way hope
well no because this happened to philza
i've been i've
investigated this when he played
hardcore and and uh
he said that they fixed it mojen saw the
glitch and that they fixed the glitch
and we're going balls deep on this [ __ ]
i ain't doing it if i die i die that
happens
hell yes
that chisel jaw man
sick sick when i was like
13 or 12 i was obsessed with troy
i thought it was the coolest thing this
ancient city and all the stories of the
battle
and i couldn't understand like i read
this really uh
kid version of the iliad and i was like
wait so like the gods like helped out
during battles
back then holy [ __ ] dude that's so
[ __ ] cool
and now i read it as an adult and i'm
like the gods are helping in the battle
that is so [ __ ] cool
it came full circle read aliyah my
brothers
it's really [ __ ] good bonky a girl
who has very big and jiggly ass
damn that girl has a bonky god damn
that's a thick bonky
[ __ ]
how much is a 10 uber right how heavy is
the 10 kilo one
it's my
no i am very smart look at the size of
my brain
so how heavy is the 10 kilo one roughly
30
333 cockroaches thank you
finally an intellectual will actually
understand my question
we must be on the exact same amount of
brain mass
well done don't touch my couch big pp on
you my sir
a true scholar it's that bell curve you
have the
the left side is oh yeah how much is the
10 kilowatt
metal is haha what an idiot right side
top iq
333 cockroaches beach
oh my god you guys need to let it go man
you need to let it go
stop it i'm downvoting these from now on
my dad and brother did an interview on
local news while sitting in pewdiepie
chair
oh yeah look at look at that great
posture
that straight and tall spine incredible
it looks serious though are you guys
okay for real
we'd like to salute pewds for this
absolute chad position
yeah it's comfy am i not allowed to be
comfy anymore
these are not my legs it's just the
mirror mirror
you you you can't see them here but you
see them in the mirror it's an
artificial intelligent uh ai of the
artificial intelligence ai
rest in peace in peace
ah he gave them to kindergartners that's
cute
that's big peepee appears in his video
feuds in his livestream
future in real life youtube music video
yeah that pretty much sums it up well
done
never seen a meme so accurate that video
was made in 2019 and this is deep now
and i'm not even 14. this is some
something that died around 2021
because too many people were getting
offended by it coco
so saying [ __ ] we're all boomers now
are we boomers are we 14 and this is
deep i can't tell
everyone [ __ ] that [ __ ] was up
and and coco was taken down and i i
gotta say
what a what a song it's just a bad song
not coco obviously
like ignore the music video completely
the song is terrible
what the [ __ ] is she i was very
disappointed
cool swedish guy epic minecraft storage
system
and it's just getting more epic every
single
day i wake up and i think how can i
improve
my epic minecraft storage system how can
i fine
it how can i get more bitched with it so
i can turn them down obviously
how to pronounce the japanese word
correctly
okay
that's too long
look what i found what
amazing incredible well done guys
super fun lawyer as always check out the
marzia g fuel pewdiepie
cup link in the description i'll see you
tomorrow
wish you a great week brofist